just a few days ago these people were
fleeing the war in ukraine now they are
arriving in berlin
after a journey which has lasted many
hours
the chaos of the last week has separated
many from their families and brought
them to a city which is welcoming them
as refugees
for some the experience has been
overwhelming
i was on the train from kiev
when the bomb started to fall
i can still hear the explosions in my
ears now
the whole train was shaking
we have no plan
i
i don't just
we run we run
and don't know what to do
i want to work
and
send money in ukraine
to help the army and
ukraine
and for the many still stuck in the war
zone there are people here trying to
help them
assembling packages of essential
supplies as at this center in potsdam
or in berlin where some people have
initiated their own donation campaign
collecting food water and clothing which
can then be taken on by ukrainian truck
drivers
you come here we balance
they come here we load them up and they
go to ukraine and in ukraine the
volunteers will then receive them and
then distribute the stuff to the needed
towns or villages wherever the help is
needed
for the established charities here the
need is clear
german red cross officials say their
ukrainian colleagues need is great
it's barely a week since russia invaded
ukraine and these are some of the first
people to make it all the way here as
refugees there but maybe many many more
dominic kane al jazeera at berlin's main
train station